fischiare
[Musica]
raffreddore
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che
sono venute sono fa vj oggi siamo dati
su reazioni a pubblicità giapponesi c'è
un motivo se si fa allora credo
fortemente che questa non sarà la
copertina del video ma forse mi sbaglio
square enix o che allora queste final
fantasy
no non è vero potrebbe non essere
praticamente però il tipo drive non ho
mai capito una sega delle canzoni
giapponesi però sono troppo verde cioè
il j pop che proprio un next level la
tipa che salva un tipo che sta morendo
il contrario vivessimo la tipa si stufa
dell'altra che sta cantando era un gioco
ovviamente non lo sapevo ci potrà essere
tra ovviamente un film bella non mi
sembrava per niente la pubblicità di un
gioco però vabbè andiamo avanti c'è uno
su un autobus che salterà non devi per
forza metterle vestita non vestita puoi
anche metterla non fa niente c'è non è
che devi attirare per forza l'attenzione
maschile come faccio io con le coperte
andiamo avanti ragazzi è un altro gioco
mese sono la pubblicità solo di giochi
praticamente oggi sono io quando mi alzo
la mattina agli stessi capelli
riuscito a far migliaia di gianpi
bravissimo pubblicità era comunque
ragazzi bastate non è vero continuiamo
io non so più cosa fare della mia vita
continuiamo così guardiamo pubblicità
giapponesi tutto il giorno incredibile
quanto nelle pubblicità giapponesi sui
videogiochi incredibile la pubblicità ci
sono dette nei videogiochi le pulci ai
videogiochi sono teste non capisco il
motivo è esagerato come se piace sono
solo ai videogiocatori che piacciono a
tutti ragazzi cosa stiamo facendo qua
sommesso no
topolino qualcosa con topolino vabbè non
ne posso più
basta vi prego vi prego come guarda come
sta guardalo come sofferente povero
ragazzo guarda guarda lei come cattiva
in questo momento io non so veramente
non ci posso fare
proprio dio bellissimo ho finalmente
abulicità di videogiochi dove non ci
sono le dette ora troppo presto partito
bellissimo anno anno hanno rifatto la
tokyo tower cioè praticamente l'anno
modificata con gli effetti bellissima
sta roba
io che ci sono stato mi fa un effetto
incredibile ma anche voi l'avete vista
per il video bellissimo madonna che
effetto
se questa fare la somma questa una
pubblicità mamma mia mamma mi son sempre
i videogiochi però ormai credo che
questo sia la speciale videogiochi
guardate grido fronti
curricolo di casa che cazzo è successo
aspetta aspetta aspettato dimmi la
madonna
ma cosa ti abbiamo fatto che cercavo di
capire di unirli incontra niente senza i
strike sarebbe una specie di versione
giapponese di counter strike allora non
stanno facendo niente di tutto questo
sul telefono voi lo sapete dove però le
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è considerato come gioco facetime no
come si chiamava la roba lì si
modificava la faccia ai tempi adesso su
instagram nella bella crociera un
pochino di politica alla faccia line
[Musica]
io mi ma mi immagino e tutto questo se
guardate guardate questo video dalla
dalla prospettiva di un anziano che tipo
o anche adulto che non sa bene come
funzionano ste robe e si vede dei
ragazzi che vanno in giro per strada
facendo così tristi figuri di oggi che
fanno le faccine agli schermi
oscar savonesi quando mangio dura
[Musica]
preso team mate carte
se cai così mani
[Musica]
ma come ha fatto la blizzard
scusate ma su stone ragazzi non so sono
lo compro a noi gratis scaricate hurston
adesso aspetta aspetta cosa avete notato
di questa pubblicità incredibile cosa
abbiamo notato ragazzi lo faccio vedere
meglio
guardate un po cosa notate cosa notate
qua
notiamo la spada incredibile madonna che
bella sto spalla comunque ragazzi la
cosa che mi fa più strano e terni non ho
mai giocato a queste cosine mobile ma in
generale per non quelli giapponesi come
in generale mobile ho mai giocato
veramente forse solo hartson davvero non
so come mai ma i giochi muovendo ma non
hai preso detto prima ponevano
tantissimo perché i giapponesi sono
fuori di casa hanno tantissimi giovani
tutti gli oneri ci giocano sulla m
nella pausa pranzo quindi non possono
tornare a casa eccetera e quindi hanno
giocato per questo vanno così tanto
gioco credo per deduco dalla mia
incredibile intelligenza tutto questo
sta tanto questa pubblicità incredibile
quanto mi dispiace per montare del monte
anzi terrae monete 0 molto esame sulla
madonna
finché rinnova tutta la cucina
complimenti perché skill domande farvi
vedere un attimo questa del monte come è
stata brava noi ragazzi incredibile
vorrei che guarda che maestria nel
girare il coso di temi che un effetto al
computer no ragazzi pazzesco non è
caduto niente ma come hai fatto
[Musica]
madonna che trip voglio lo voglio lo
compro tranquille lo compro lo compro
date melo il video dei video i soldi che
è successo
mamma donna mamma gara lo stanno facendo
tutto il tempo così va bene mi piace o
mio dio
salve ma cosa sta bene ha offerto un
borsello con la faccia da gatto ha un
gatto ragazzi cosa sto vedendo cosa ho
visto ma cosa che io io mi chiedono come
fanno i gatti sono infatti al computer
non stare però mai su musica non è
possibile che l'ha fatto al computer non
ci credo maronna che ansia o addio dal
pilato alla fine tutto il successo che
cos'è che volato non ho visto c'è la
finale ma basta vi basta ragazzuoli sono
una donna arson mi ha veramente
scioccato spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che questa vicenda sono stato il
vostro gradimento che vi facciamo
spendere un sacco di soldi da non è vero
sono sempre più convinto di volermi
trasferire in giappone ragazzi non so se
si è capito non per la copertina del
video c'è anche per questo soprattutto
per quello fare solo per quello aveva
comunque sia il giappone è fantastico a
prescindere quando andate li vedete cose
c'è voi non avete mai viste le
pubblicità tipo nei cartelloni
pubblicitari giapponesi sono veramente
incredibili ci sono delle robe loreti
stupiscono in tutto quindi se io vivessi
in giappone comprare qualsiasi cosa mi
sponsorizzano tutto per avere sia
piaciuto lasciato un bel like
iscrivetevi al canale e schiacciate una
bellissima campanellina che vedete
vicino a tassi iscriviti che molto
importante e non ci vediamo come sempre
allora ragazzi
[Musica]